who do you think is the the best
up-and-coming politician obviously you
know trump has been there biden's been
there bernie's been there nancy pelosi
has been there you know
john mccain i mean the list goes on on
mcconnell these guys are in their 70s
80s
who in their 40s do you look at and say
damn that guy's got it or that girl's
got it who who comes to mind these days
the young up-and-comers
i don't know that we know who that
person is yet
it could be somebody from outside of
politics i do think that more and more
people who are outside of politics could
be helpful to the system
i do think this though i would say
you know i
i
america is so divided when i came home
so much has changed i didn't recognize
my party
you know it was uh
eight years that i was gone and you know
social media all this stuff is so
different now right
everything is so quick and people have
all these views it was just important
that they have those this idea of
canceled culture and this wokeness it's
a very different thing and a very
dangerous thing i think i think freedom
is in danger in the united states
and i think that
the hyper partisan nature of our
politics is making things worse not
better and i don't know that i have a
direct solution to it because both
parties are sort of locked into their
positions it's all about winning the
next election i do think the republicans
going to have a very good year 2022 and
i do think there's a realignment going
on in american politics which could be
very helpful and get us back on a good
track
but i i think the hyper partisanship is
so extreme
that it's just turning off too many
people and dividing us too much it would
be nice to see some person come out who
might be able to find a way to unify
without selling out his or her
principles
and so a guy like reagan had that
ability roosevelt had that ability
lincoln had that ability
somebody like that do i see anybody in
the horizon right now i don't i'm
obviously very biased towards president
trump for what he did for me
i mean i think stylistically
you know you he is what he is some
people love it some people don't
but i do think that
a lot of the stuff he's been working at
and talking about
is right for america so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]